le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
offrir le meilleur développement
possible à des enfants séparés de leur
famille c'est la mission quotidienne des
assistants familiaux
cette année le métier fête les 10 ans de
la professionnalisation
à cette occasion nous partons à la
rencontre de georgette assistante
familiale à la retraite et fatima il
vient de recevoir son agrément
[Musique]
mes deux enfants énorme et dans cette
chambre est par ici il y avait une autre
lit à l'étagé se fait que les deux
enfants en dab dormait là en tout ces 33
enfants que georgette a logé nourri et
et mais toujours dans la bonne humeur
il n'y avait pas de soucis et les
rançons des ailes d'un mois accueilli à
leur part alors on était bien on
rigolait avec amour au manger on sait
j'ai tout avec amour la dionysienne a
été assistante familiale pendant 40 ans
sa mission accueillir des enfants au
contexte familial difficile et leur
offrir un cadre de vie rassurant et
épanouissant ni aimait tellement les
enfants parce que mal a toujours occupé
des enfants les enfants de mes soeurs
quand il travaillait c'était comme est
donc pour moi mieux mais les enfants
c'était l'amour d'une maman pour les
enfants je fais et ça avec le coeur
malgré leur dévotion à l'époque celle
que l'on appelait encore nourrice était
en mal de reconnaissance avant honda n'y
ait pas beaucoup on gagnait tout juste
deux ans à 2500 francs pour deux enfants
trois enfants ont travaillé sur le tas
avant il n'y avait pas beaucoup de
personnes comme pour nous aider et quand
notre travail il était reconnu nous
faisait des formations c'est la
compagnie un petit peu plus
[Musique]
cette année le métier fête ses dix ans
de professionnalisation l'occasion pour
georges est de partager son expérience
j'ai fait qu'il faut en noir le lien
mais il faut être un peu à distance pour
que l'enfant est sous sa propre marque
lion pour la première fois tous les
acteurs se sont réunis pour échanger sur
la vocation un moyen de reconnaître et
valoriser les compétences des assistants
familiaux on se rend compte aujourd'hui
que les assistantes familiales elles ont
des connaissances sur donc les enfants
elles peuvent effectivement donner des
avis par rapport aux observations donc
elles font dans le quotidien sur les
difficultés donc de l'enfant et les
ramener vers donc les référents et les
équipes qui les aident et les
soutiennent plus dans voilà
l'élaboration en fait donc des projets
qui sont mises en oeuvre pour les
enfants confiés à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
aujourd'hui le conseil départemental
propose un meilleur accompagnement pour
ces merdeux coeur - d'isolement elles
sont associées au niveau donc des des
instances techniques elles sont
associées également au niveau des
instances départementales qui les
concernent
voilà par rapport à des informations
préoccupantes par rapport donc à au
dispositif en fête d'accueil familial de
manière générale est-ce que parmi vous
il ya des as femmes qui accueille donc
des adolescents qui accueille également
des jeunes majeurs qu'est ce que la sto
familiale
en place pour sa du nourrisson à
l'adolescent les assistants familiaux
doivent s'adapter à chaque enfant
à chacun son caractère à chacun son
histoire une histoire qu'il est parfois
nécessaire de partager ou d'oublier
l'espace d'un instant ce matin ce groupe
d'assistante familiale s'initie au yoga
du rire
une manière originale de se détendre et
de lâcher prise
on va se partager ce moment en faisant
on l'a autorisé à tirer la langue à part
une grosse limace tous ensemble
fatima est une nouvelle assistante
familiale hésitante au début du cours la
jeune femme se prend très vite au jeu et
laisse de côté pendant quelques minutes
les difficultés du quotidien placement
de l'enfant qui était autiste quelques
semaines c'est très dur parce qu'elle a
aussi un appart pour les formations
c'est pas facile et ensuite j'ai eu une
ado de 16 ans travaille comme stressant
parce qu'on est un petit peu les bras ni
même en étant assistant familial
à la maison 24 24 avec le bout d'une
heure l'objectif est atteint
c'est un fou rire garanti dans la salle
[Applaudissements]
cet atelier fait partie de
l'accompagnement proposé par le
département
si le métier a évolué et les assistants
familiaux d'hier et d'aujourd'hui garde
pourtant une chose en commun l'amour et
le don de soi c'est un métier qui
nécessite beaucoup de deux présents
c'est beaucoup d'investissement et c'est
pas facile de prendre en charge les
enfants les enfants des orques ou kanu
des parlements nous l'avons biasion pour
leur investissement dans ce métier qui
n'est pas facile mais en tout cas bravo
vous assistante familiale
les assistants familiaux ont pour rôle
d'offrir un enfant séparé de sa famille
des conditions de vie permettant un bon
développement physique psychique
affective et sociale
ils peuvent accueillir jusqu'à trois
enfants de moins de 21 ans pour pouvoir
accueillir ces enfants
l'assistant doit obtenir un agrément
délivré par le conseil départemental
avant tout accueille les assistants
familiaux doivent bénéficier d'un stade
préparatoire de 60 heures tout en
suivant en alternance une formation de
240 heures débouchant sur un diplôme
d'état pour plus d'informations rendez
vous sur le site du département au
www.cglpl.fr ou contacter le service
protection maternelle et infantile au 02
62 90 33 24
[Musique]